En un instrumento de cuerda, la longitud de la cuerda, déjame llamarle "l", a esta longitud,
es inversamente proporcional
a la frecuencia de sus vibraciones
a la frecuencia le voy a poner "f".
Entonces nos dice que la longitud es
inversamente proporcional a "f"
de esta forma, podemos escribir a "l"
como una constante que le vamos a poner "k",
la constante de proporcionalidad,
multiplicada por el inverso de la frecuencia,
multiplicada por 1 entre "f".
Muy bien, luego nos dicen,
las vibraciones hacen que los instrumentos suenen,
ah, eso está muy padre,
bueno, sigamos.
Una cuerda de 11 cm, de hecho esto está muy padre,
o sea las vibraciones de la cuerda,
y pues viajan a través del aire ,de ahí llegan al oído,
en el oído hacen que el tímpano vibre
después eso se comunica con el oído medio,
con el oído interno,
y por allá hay una cierta magia
que hace que oigamos.
Pero ahorita no nos queremos concentrar
en porqué oímos,
sino queremos continuar con el problema,
entonces déjame seguir,
Dice, una cuerda de 11 cm,
esto suena a una longitud, la voy a marcar con amarillo,
tiene una frecuencia
de 400 ciclos por segundo,
frecuencia en rosa,
y nos dicen,
encuentra la constante de proporcionalidad,
o sea tenemos que determinar "k"...
k...
y luego la frecuencia de una cuerda de 10 cm,
otra longitud más.
Bueno,
entonces vamos a hacer esto por partes ¿vale?
Vamos a empezar encontrando
la constante de proporcionalidad.
Y para eso vamos a utilizar esta información
en esta igualdad,
lo que nos dicen es que 11 cm,
que es la longitud,
11 cm es igual a "k"
la constante de proporcionalidad,
multiplicada por 1 entre la frecuencia
y aquí nos dicen exactamente quién es la frecuencia
nos dicen que la frecuencia es,
400 ciclos por segundo...
400 ciclos...
por segundo...
Muy bien, entonces lo primero que tenemos que hacer,
es despejar "k"
y para eso vamos a multiplicar por
400 ciclos por segundo de ambos lados,
400 ciclos por segundo...
aquí a la derecha
y también aquí a la izquierda.
400 ciclos...
por segundo...
segundo...
y justo la idea de hacer esto es que del lado derecho,
se cancele este con este
y nos quede que "k"
que "k"
es igual a esta multiplicación,
400 por 11,
pues 400 por 10 es 4000
más 400 es 4400.
Y déjame seguir con las unidades
para que veamos que todo va bien,
entonces, sería ciclos por centímetros sobre segundo,
ciclos por centímetro
sobre segundo.
Muy bien, entonces observa que a partir de aquí
podemos reescribir esta igualdad,
ahora sí con el valor de "k".
Podemos poner que la longitud es igual a 4400.
4400 ciclos por segundo, no...
ciclos por centímetro sobre segundo,
y eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por 1
sobre la frecuencia...
por 1 sobre la frecuencia...
Muy bien, ahora con esto en mente,
lo que nos piden es la frecuencia de una cuerda
de longitud 10 centímetros.
Entonces ahora podemos utilizar esta igualdad
conociendo el valor de "l",
y de ahí despejar "f",
vamos a hacer eso.
Entonces sabemos que "l" ahora es 10 cm,
entonces sabemos que 10 cm es igual a 4400
4.400 ciclos por cm sobre segundo...
ciclos por centímetro sobre segundo...
multiplicado por 1 sobre la frecuencia...
por 1 sobre la frecuencia.
Entonces,
voy a multiplicar ambos lados de esta igualdad,
por la frecuencia
para que me quede del lado izquierdo,
y además voy a dividir entre 10 cm,
para que se cancele esto,
10 cm y aquí entre 10 cm.
Muy bien,
entonces ¿qué nos queda?
éste se cancela con éste,
la frecuencia con esta frecuencia se cancelan,
vaya se hacen un 1,
centímetros se va con centímetros
y 4400 entre 10 es 440.
De esta forma nos queda que la frecuencia,
la frecuencia es igual a 400,
440 ciclos...
ciclos por segundo...
y esto está súper bien, porque ciclos por segundos
es una unidad de frecuencia.
Bueno, vamos a meditar un poquito que sucedió,
al principio la cuerda era de 11 cm
y la frecuencia era de 400 ciclos por segundo
y después estamos disminuyendo
la longitud de la cuerda,
pero la frecuencia aumentó
a 440 ciclos por segundo.
Entonces en efecto, pues aquí en el fondo,
hay una relación inversamente proporcional, ¿vale?
Bueno, espero que te haya gustado,
nos vemos hasta la próxima.